其实从这个标题我们就可以看出
none night这个团队的话确实是野心勃勃
那首先讲它要解决的问题是什么
实际上的话呢
这个是我从他的那个官方的那个塔
叫做journey to the nut中截的这张图
我个人还是蛮喜欢这张图的
因为其实从我开始做这个就rendering开始啊
其实我们是每一个做渲染的人
脑中都有一个梦想
就是说我们希望在计算机的世界里面
还原真实的世界
但如果大家真的观察一下真实的世界
你会发现哇这个大自然实在是太美了
我我以前经常举了一个例子
就是说你在海边看那个浪花
去拍拍击那个那个海岸
特别像这种岩时代
你看到那种无穷无尽的那种细节的时候
你就能知道说哎呀
我们的渲染
其实离这种realistic真的还是非常的遥远
这其实是所有的做渲染的同同学的话
心中的一个梦想
就是我们也希望达到这种
就是我们叫cinematic
就是电影级的这样的一个精度
这其实也是所有实时渲染的人
他无论是做硬件的还是做算法的
大家心中的这样的一个梦想
所以其实none night
它就是这个作者他一直在思考的问题
就是说我们怎么样子
在这个游戏引擎的pipeline中
实现这种无限的几何细节
那这件事情的话呢其实啊非常的复杂
所以今天呢我再去讲nana的这个技术的时候
其实我遇到一个非常大的挑战是什么呢
就是说啊这个技术我读了他的所有的这个
原始的这个文档
我发现就是说其实他比较晦涩
就是他讲的这个东西的话
其实有很多的细节
很多关键性的东西
其实你要花很长时间去猜
所以呢这是我自己尝试整理了一下
就是今天我讲的第一部分
我想讲就是none night
他最开始的思考就是all of you
就是他为什么选择了这个solution
第二个呢
第二part也是今天的重点
就是说也是nt最核心的
就是说它的几何到底是怎么去表达的
而且这个几何你没有两个东西
特别容易混淆
一个就是诶
我去cluster构建了它的l o d体系对吧
哎后面他还做了一个叫b v h这个东西
这个bbs他讲的
我个人觉得是最没有讲清楚的部分
但是后来逼得我们看了很多的代码
才能能猜出他大概是怎么做的
然后呢接下来就讲
如果我们有这样的一个表达之后
诶
我们去怎么去做它的渲染
这里面其实有很多的很关键性的一些实施
比如说基于软光上化
在这里面起的作用对吧
他是怎么去用这个vivisibility buffer的技术
做shading
因为nat是一个实战型的
这个游戏引擎技术
所以它的材质会非常的复杂
那么多的材质它怎么处理
还有呢就是说诶
我的材质就有那么多的材质
那么你有了这么详细的几何
接下来另外一个挑战
刚才我在反复强调的是什么
就是如果你的几何做了足够的细
那你在做shadow的时候
你也就更头疼
因为你的几何的complexity在急剧的增加
所以其实这个时候在虚幻五里面
提出了一个很重要的技术叫virtual shadow map
我个人觉得这个技术也是非常了不起的
一个技术
那最后呢
其实我个人觉得在原作中讲了大量的什么
我怎么去做streaming啊
怎么去做压缩啊
我个人觉得那可能是更多的是一些
implementation detail
所以呢当然我会点一下
但是我希望今天的重点是
能够把几何的representation跟大家讲清楚
这个也是啊倾尽了我们课程组的权力吧
希望小伙伴们不要跟我们砖头
如果讲错了的话
也欢迎大家给我们更正好
那我们先讲nana它到底是怎么个源头
其实呢我个人去理解这件事情
我首先想到的一个词就是virtual texture
因为virtual texture的其实是啊
如果我没记错啊
是这个游戏引擎的发明者对吧
那个哎叫什么来着
突然想不起来了
对
反正就是写quick的那个老哥哇
我的我的我心中的神
我居然忘了他叫什么名字了
这个实在是太过分了对吧
那么那个就是他呢提出来的这样的
一个一个一个核心思想
就是说他说呢
我们在一个真实的游戏场景里面
有很多的物体
每个物体都有自己的tt
这个text数量是非常非常大的
我没有办法这么多texture全部装入内存
存也不可能哦
也谢谢大家在弹幕里提醒我啊
对john k对
然后哎呀
这个罪过罪过大神的名字我都忘记了
对这个确实是最近脑子里填的东西太多了
ok john camer确实非常了不起
就是他在我如果没记错的话
好像是在quick 3的时代
还是那个他提出了
就是说应该是q3 之后一点
他其实是virtual text思想
每个物体有大量的tt
这text如果全部加载的内存
显存其实都会炸的
但是呢我能不能给一个budget
就是说在当前的我的这个相机的位置
我能看到的世界
其实根据近处texture的精度高
远处texture精度低
我实际上可以形成一个texture的这样的一个
a clip map
那么我可以在一个限定的八gt里面
把我当前view下的所有需要的材质的texture
全部给他cash起来
那这样的话
实际上他就提供了一个unify的表达
去表达所有的材质
那这样还有更大更大的好处是什么呢
就是说大家还记得我前面讲的传统的render
pipeline里面对吧
我要不停的
我每次换一次材质
我都要切一次他的这个render dd
对不对
我要换一下哎
我设置我的ab to text是什么
这个这个这个这个这个diffuse texture是什么
对吧
我的那个spectre text
什么那个roughetexture是什么
那这个东西其实叫起来就很麻烦了
对不对
那如果我把它全拍到了一个巨大的versity
texture里面的话
诶我至少在材质切换这一趴
我一次性就搞定了
这其实是个非常了不起的一个想法
那个turn rendering的时候
其实tern rendering
实际上用的也是这个virtual texture这个思想
所以这个这个方法呢
实际上对于啊游戏引擎来讲的话
是一个非常elegant的一个一个一个solution
真的非常的美
非常的美
就是啊大家如果搞系统架构的人的话
就会感受到这种就是这种系统架构之美吧
或者是算法之美
确实他是非常了不起的一件事情
所以呢我not net的作者
他就在这是我盗用他的p p t啊
这里面我用了一部分他的原始的p p t
就是说他的梦想是什么诶
我能不能够把几何也virtualize变成一个virtualize
geetry对吧
也就是说我因为我知道在screen space
在我的屏幕上有多少个像素
我的几何数量不可能超过我的像素数量
所以我每一刻
我只要渲染了几百万个三角形就可以了
对吧
而且我的周末要尽可能简单
但是呢这就要求什么呢
我要对这个几何
这个就是他有个方法能够进行filtering
能够进行进行处理
而且我一旦我达到了每个像素
一个三角形的话
其实我也达到了fmc
就是说电影级别的这种画质
这就是他的一个梦想
但是真正的挑战是什么呢
就是说其实几何的数据
就像我前面在讲到那个lumen的时候
反复强调一件事情
就是什么
哎呀几何的数据是一个irregular data
对不对
它是一个就是不是uniform data
那这个时候你对他进行各种处理
比如说这个ping啊
loading啊对吧
你比如说你的一个index buffer
他可能说我在画一个mesh
他可能在verse
八经跳到了一个非常远的地方对吧
你只能把整个vb搂进来
你不能把它一段段的load进来
大家想想是不是还有什么呢
还有那个就是说诶我的几何
我的l o d0 和d一的那个match
其实彼此之间可能没有关联性对吧
它是两个完全不同的mesh
当然了
你可以说有些vertex 5可以reuse
那我可以就同一到vb
但是两道不同的index
但是那个它的filter其实是不连续的
所以jg ree其实是非常难以进行filter
为什么filter呢
所以大家想要texture对吧
近处你看到非常的细
到远处哎
越来越熟越来越熟越来越熟
对于这种有风的data的话
你是比较好去过滤的
那这里面可以好filter的数据有没有呢
有啊对吧
大家还记得我在讲入门的时候
为什么我大吹特吹
sdf这个东西确实很很酷啊
就是因为sdf它可以过滤啊对吧
你可以对他信形成各种各样的密码
但是呢sdf实在是太粗了
我没有办法在它直接进行绘制
那么我还有别的什么方法呢
可以用voxel的方法对吧
用像素的就用那个vocal
就是vocal
不要叫体术
对体术的方法去对它进行表达
我还可以用什么呢
point cloud floud是什么呢
就是说啊大家有没有用过那个scanner
就是那个呃3d scanner对吧
其实3d的scanner
它扫出来的其实原始数据就是点云
我们为什么看到那么漂亮的几何
它其实是基于点云重建的
那么这些数据呢诶好像是可以filtering
所以作者呢他就在他思考他自己呢
他把这些东西都全部过了一遍
其实啊我我个人还是蛮欣赏他的工作的
就是说他在决定做nana的这个方案之前
其实是便利了几乎所有的可能性
比如他讲的worko对吧
那worko呢
这个东西呢确实是一个非常uniform的表达
当然works so有两个很大的问题是什么呢
第一个就是说它的本身的数据量
其实还是很难压下去的
特别是如果你想表达那种非常高频的in的
这种边界的话
那works slide表达
其实他就要求那个works的精度很高
实际上啊它的数量还是惊人
诶他的这个数据你对它进行filtering啊
进行处理啊
就变得非常的费
大家还记得我们上一节课讲
len讲全局光照的时候
有一个基于sparse orchestre的方法
去做gi的那个方法
你有没有发现我讲的那一趴的时候
我讲的就非常的简单
非常的跳
为什么呢
那个算法好像我们没有找到他的source code
我们一直很担心
那个算法自己实现起来会有很多的坑
为什么
因为他对这个世界的表达太复杂了
那么其实另外一个呢
我个人觉得这是作者非常重要的一个观察
就是说其实现在我们的整个
比如说艺术家的pipeline
比如说你用max maya对吧
zbrush生成的所有的资产
他都不是基于worker的去表达的
那么如果我今天为了我实时渲染的目的
我要逼着你把所有的asset资产
变成worker li的表达的话
那这个成本是不是很惊人的
大家想想看对吧
所以说其实也是基于这个原因
虽然worko的表达
有非常好的这种filtering的个性
你甚至它的密铺啊非常的方便
但是的话呢作者到最后还是把它by pass style
我个人觉得就是存储是一回事
但是这个就是说不你对传统pipeline呢
就传统艺术家的管线的工作的
实际上是啊致命的对
因为我们自己在做一个心情嘛
我们非常清楚的知道一件事情
就是说你必须要尊重
那么第二种方法呢
其实也是
现在这个就是说gpu猛推的一个东西
就是说比如说我们在看在这个10年之前
我们就提出了这个jb shader对吧
我们提出了这种mesh shader这些概念
就意味着我们可以on the flight
增加很多几何的这个这个这个就是精细度
以前那个叫什么whole whole shader对吧
还有dman shader这些很奇怪的词
说实话我到现在都很痛恨这些名词的命名
我觉得明明一个我能懂的东西
结果他名字一命我就不懂了
那他其实核心要解决的问题是什么呢
就是诶我有一个粗的集合
我可以在软碳
要用类似于这种subdivision的方法
就是把这个几何呢给他再继续细分
subdivision的意思就是细分曲面嘛对吧
我可以用各种各样的样条啊
各种各样的控制点的方法
可以把它几何面变得无比的光滑
其实这种subdivision faces啊
就是这种几何
实际上呢它有几个特点
第一个就是真正在啊
如果没记错的话
在电影工业里面用的是特别特别多的
那么那时候你看到的很多几何
它都是a4 边形面
大家想象我们渲染的基本上是三角形对吧
但是哎如果你想用subtivation的话
他说你得要用四边形面
那么这个四边形面呢
实际上在我们的艺术家
在做这个一些精细的模型的时候
他一上来全部用的都是四边形面
帮助他们造型
对这个跟大家理解可能不太一样
那么好了
我有这样一个四边形面
作为一个control points的话
那我其实可以形成一个cage
然后呢我可以形成很多很细的几何
那么这个时候呢哎我对它进行细分的话
我就会形成很多我们想要的那种
光溜溜的几何细节
但是呢作者这里面
他讲了他这个subtification的很多的问题嘛
我个人觉得
其实如果我要去实现一个
像nat这样的技术的话
最卡住我的东西是什么呢
你的subdivision呢
他只能不断的去refine
比如说美术做一匹小马对吧
他做了一个5000个面的
这个马的这个这个原始版本
我可以把它all the way of sampling到100万个面
没有问题
但是如果这个小马离我非常非常远
我希望就是几百个面就表达的时候
诶他subdivision不能够往下进行
当三
那这个你会发现就是在not net实现中的话
它每一个对象它其实可以all the way
减到100多个面
甚至可以减减到一个imposter
这一点上
其实当我在大规模的应用这个技术的时候
肯定就会有问题对吧
所以这也是作者
他自己就是pass掉这个方案的一个
很核心的原因
那么另外一个呢
这也是啊
我们在这个图形渲染领域里面
讲了很多年了
就是a displaced map啊对吧
这些这个这些这些技术
我可以在一个一个cross的cost的三角形面上
增加很多的几何
这个方法好不好
当然非常好了对吧
但是作者他就说
如果你要用这个方法去做一些硬表面的时
候
你那个design map是很难去设置的
他说你做出来做这种organic的
这个方面的效果是非常的好
而且呢它确实可以做ft
但是呢
如果你要表达一些非常硬的一些东西的时
候
它很难
另外一个就是
假设我拿到一个很精细的几何
我怎么去生成一个比较好的design map
这本身呢还是需要一些运算的
但是这一趴我个人觉得是啊nana的这个技术
大家现在debate最多的东西
如果大家关注最新的这个
nvidia的发布会的时候
你会发现他四零减显卡专门提出一个东西
叫做啊叫叫叫啊
应该叫michael mash吧对吧
其实也就是说mv的同学还是在猛推
就是说诶基于这种这个gpu的方法
我自动的把你的几何加密
然后呢我还可以在上面做retracing
这套方法就是不要再用你那么复杂的
哪来的那套技术对吧
所以我觉得其实在未来的10年的话
就是到底是nt这套方法是会成为王者
还是基于硬件的对吧
我还是用这个几何
用硬件去加密几何对吧
这里面我当然可能用的是map
可能用的其他的技术
然后呢同手环的兼容retracing啊对吧
更复杂的一些光照啊
这个地方是大家
我个人认为现在还没有决出这个生死的
这样一个战斗
我感觉是我看得非常清楚
就是两派都在这个快速的往前走吧
所以这个呢当然作者会认为
这个方法其实不是特别通用
那么最后一个作者就是这个a提了
提到了就是说诶point in the base的方法
我渲染结果怎么样
首先pinbase方法做filtering是非常方便的
但是呢
如果你要达到这种我屏幕绘制进度的话
其实他其实那个point of running是在屏幕上叫spring
就是我打一个个的小小小disco上去对吧
那实际上对于每个像素的话
很可能有很多的overjo
而且你要达到一个比较高的精度的话呢
那个效果其实并不是特别好
其实也是比较大的问题
所以的话呢
作者分析了这些的表达方法之后
作者说
所以呢我的选择是很明确的
我要选择三角形
因为三角形呢是大家最熟悉
最成熟的一种几何表达形式
整个的这个content pipeline
就是所谓的比如3d max maya zbrush
这些工具全面支持对吧
另外一个硬件上对他的支持
也是最最成熟的
所以呢它的整个那个无限几何的解决方案
都是基于三角形构建的
所以作者做出这个选择
这也是none night的一个foundation
那既然我们选择用三角形
那这个几何到底是怎么构建的呢
哎这个真正难的问题就来了
就是在nt里面几何到底怎么去表达好
那其实呢他这他这里面
作者提出了一个一个一个思想
它的原作讲的是说诶我这个几何数量
int数量可以持续增加
但是呢我希望我绘制的三角形数量
不要跟着它持续的增加
因为为什么呢
其实我个人的理解是这样的
就是说你无论增加多大的场景复杂度
在屏幕上你的像素数是一定的
对不对
那么好
你有多少个像素
原则上一个像素对吧
一个三角形或者两个三元就够了
那我其实就可以算出来说
在任何一个view下
你应该绘制多少个三角形
所以说我们有没有可能像virtual text一样
就是根据我屏幕的这个精度
决定了我的这个geometry
诶这个cing的精度
这两个时间能不能建立一个对应关系
这其实也就是拿来一个
最最核心的一个思想好
那我们有假设有这么多这么细密的几何
我们怎么去表达它呢
诶他首先第一个思想就是说
其实跟刚才我讲的那个就是啊
class based rendering
我对这种细密的几何
我把它分成一个个的cluster对吧
这是我们的课程组的小伙伴自己做的啊
这个原作没有
我们自己搞了一条dragon
然后呢我们把它分成了无数个cluster
用的是nana一样的算法
你可以看到这样的很多的cluster
好
这个方法很简单
对不对
好
我有了这样class的表达
make a cluster
比如说是128个三角形组成的
对不对啊
接下来我就可以做一件很淳朴的事情了
我们这个这也是nat
我个人认为是非常强的一件事情
就是说他的技术可以实现一个叫view
dependent
lo d transition
就是说对于这样一条dragon
它是有240万个面构成的
对不对
但是呢哦是对2400万的船购构成的
那么当我的相机去看它的时候
我可以让它实现
在近处的这个显示的密度非常的高
但是呢稍微远一点点
它这个每个coser的精度就会逐渐的降低
这样我能极大的节约我的面数
这一点其实啊也是它和刺客信条那一做的
那个技术一个本质的区别
在刺客信条那个技术里面的话
它每个instance l o d level是锁死的对吧
你不可能在一个instance里面
每个caster用不同的l o d
但是呢在nt里面他真的是实现了
就是will dependent这个l o d的transition
这也是他最引以为傲的一件事情
同时也是他整个算法中
我个人认为最复杂的一部分
因为待会我会介绍几个好几个概念
这个这个概念在原始的这个报告中的话
那绝对是神坑级的这样的存在对吧
但是大家记住一个概念
就是说not that它能实现就对一个物体
一个inst
它的每一个它的cluster会切到不同的
这样的话能够实现对这个屏幕空间的
这个船口最大化的利用
那么大家可以看到这只龙的话
就是说诶
他几乎用只用了1/30的船狗
就能够实现了
就是每一个pixel
就是每个屏幕几乎有一个三角形的
这个精度
那他是怎么做到的
诶我们先讲一个最简单的算法
这个算法其实啊
这是我去他原作全部整理了一遍
因为他那个方法以前讲的就是
确实让大家混淆
我们先讲一个最简单的东西
就是说
假设我已经对这个mash
变成了很多的cluster
对吧好
我假设把每个cluster 22的去合
合了之后呢
我把cluster的团购的数量都减少一半
那我就形成了一个l o d e的
上面的cluster
对不对
然后呢我假设我下面有四个cluster
我上合一层
我就变成两个cluster
对不对
然后我再往上一层只有一个cluster
那这样的话我就可以构建一个非常简单的
这个就是这个cluster的
l o t的这个hearchy对吧
那有了这个hy呢
我每一次简化的时候
其实我会知道他的error的对吧
有几何每次简化我的error就会增加
那好在当前的这个view的情况下
我可以算出来说诶
你这个caster离我的绑定是多少对吧
我觉得能够算出来说
你的误差不高于一个pixel的
这个error tolerance是多少
如果你的class是做几何简化的时候
和你的这个原始的几何
这个误差小于一个subpixel的话
那我就觉得你可以绘制了
但如果我发现你大于的话
那怎么办
我继续往下走
所以呢我其实就可以decide一个cluster base的
l o d的这个实时的卡里的这个li
这个是不是很简单对吧
这是个非常难义务的一个solution啊
好诶如果我有这样的一个line的话
大家想象一下
我假设场景有很多很多的几何对吧
那我是不是我的streaming
也可以用这种方法去做对吧
对于那种下面很细的
但是其数量很大的那些那些翻译脚本
就是精细的几何
我其实一上来可以不加载
我先加载它的扩展的锤
当我的相机推进那个小雕像的时候
诶我发现那个l o d2 不好使了
怎么办
我就加载l o d一嘛对吧
当我发现我相机太近了
我d一都不好使了
我加载l o d0
你发现没有
诶
这个方法是就又可以实现了
那个拿来最引游也好的
就是这个这个这个几何数据
可以streaming的去加载
你想这个难用的方法
是不是
就基本把他所有的核心的需求全部解决了
对吧
这就是nana的最最基础的我们去class base的方法
但这个方法有没有问题呢
哎这个方法其实问题还是挺严重的
但问题出在哪里呢
就是说当我对这些cluster进行合并
进行简化的时候
我只要简化完之后啊
我的三角形数量少了一半
但是呢我不能保证我减耗完的那个几何
它的边和那个没有简化的几何
就比如说我这边的这几个claer
是用l o d0 绘制的对吧
我回到这张图里面
这几个cos蓝深蓝色的caster
他用的是l o d0 绘制的那个浅蓝色的
l o d e的那个caster呢
就是我被那个姓掐中的那个那个
那个那个就是那个那个coser呢
他可能是用l o d e绘制的好
那么它两个之间呢本来是watertight
水密性在一起的
但是呢他们就会形成一个我们的叫cx对吧
大家还记得我们在讲turing的时候
会有这样的cx
对不对
好
那怎么办呢
其实这个问题呢也是一个很好
很好解决的问题
怎么办
我把它的边锁住嘛对吧
就是说我每次简化的时候
我把我的class的边全部锁住对吧
这样所述之后呢
我这个cluster虽然已经切到l o d一了
但是呢我实际上这就是我跟旁边
你无论是用d0 还是d2
我们那边都能够watertight在一起对吧
但实际上你会发现它一直锁的是那个
l o d0 的那个边
那个边的话呢
三角形随着你的l o d
从012345678上去之后
你会发现
那个地方的采购的密度是永远都是很高的
那很高
那意味着什么呢
意味着两件事情
第一个你肯定你的面片简化的利用率不高
你想想看啊
比如说我在l o t0 的时候
我我最后占据的就是比如说我的l d 10
那个时候我的一个cluster
虽然只有128个
128个面
那它所表达的区域
在原来的那个几何中的区域是很大很大的
对不对
但是你要锁边
光你那边的那个是那个船口数量
可能128就远远装不下去了对吧
这个这个实际上你就没法搞了
这是第一点很头疼的事
第二点是什么呢
就是说这些边假设你不care说我就歪了了
我对高高级的l o d4567 的话
我就不加那个
128个三角形的约束了
对吧好
我这边就放在这儿
其实你会发现这个几何啊
当你去拉开来的时候
你会发现有些区域
它的几何的密度和它整体的这个密度啊
其实是就是就是nine uniform的
这个在信号采样上
你会看到一些artifacts
就是你会看到一些非常明显的那种地方
就是看起来也是连续的
但是你会notify那个地方好像很密
举个例子
这种感觉像什么呢
就像是两件衣服对吧
两块布你缝在衣服的缝合处
你可以看到那个地方
好像有秘密的缝合线的感觉一样
因为那个地方加了很多几何细节
但是他其他面上的细节全部都没有了
你会notify
就人眼是这样的
人也是一个很神奇的设备
就是我们人的大脑和眼睛
其实对高频信号非常的敏感
特别是对于franky change
就是频率发生变化的时候
我们人眼的detect的能力是非常非常高的
这个大家如果做render
你就知道就是说其实你从数值上看
它的artifact已经非常小了
但是呢人眼总是能注意到这些artifact
所以这个地方的话呢
也会产生一个很严重的问题
所以大家会发现没有哪一种方法它work对吧
如果这个方法work了
我们就很省事了
那今天的课程讲到这
我就可以回去睡觉了
就可以休息了对吧
但实际上的话呢这个方法是不work的
那怎么办
哎
not nice就提出了一个非常神奇的一个想法
这个想法
其实我个人觉得还是非常的惊讶似的
就是说他把这些cluster 10几个cluster
我变成一个叫cluster group
这个数字我有点忘了
是八个还是还是16还是32个
但是反正不重要
他自己选了一个数据
那么我的l watch锁整个classer group的边
我里面的这个in inner的这个age啊
就是这个coser之间的boundary啊
全部打打打碎掉
你们就一起去简化
这样的话呢
就是说
我实际上能够最大化地利用这个
简化所带来的好处
比如说我一个cos 128个三角形对吧
那我假设那个我把16个cluster
聚成一起的话
那我将近有2万多个三角形
对不对
好
我把这23000集合到一起
我还是锁它的边
这个边可能就1000多个三角形
但是呢
我把2万个三角形减到1万个三角形
这时候你就会发现
它的边其实没有那么痛苦了
而这个时候诶
我的简化就会变得更加的有效
那么这样做的一个这样做
这样做下去的话
你会发现
他接下来对于那个简化过的那个
1万个三角形的再做一次cover class
他把那个class的数量一下子就减了一半
这里面就是他原作给的这样的一个案例
就是说诶大家看这四个不同的颜色
就代表了四种不同的caster对吧
那个就是黄色
红色
绿色和蓝色诶
这是代表四个相应的点
就表示caster
然后呢我把它们合成一起
变成一个class group
然后我整体做出简化
但是它的整个class的外边我还是保持住啊
因为我要保持它在l o d transition的时候
是what tight的好
这个时候我就会得到就是三角形
数量减一半的三角形
然后呢我再去run co
我就会得到大概少一半的cluster
比如说你们这两个coser
你会发现
这个时候他就一个很有意思的事情
来这个这个地方也是哪里来
大家特别容易弄混的地方
就是你后面的class数量上面只有两个
但是它和下面的那个class之间的
父子关系的话
不是我们传统理解的树状的
就是一对一的关系
它是一个一对多的关系
也就是说有可能简化过的cluster
每个cluster实际上是和下面的四个的
l o d0 的cluster都有关联关系对吧
简化的l o d e的两个cluster
他两个是兄弟关系
这个关系其实是非常非常重要的好
那么它的整个这个算法的核心
就是说
我每一次把这个现在当前的这个l d0 的
比如说l0
所有的cluster把它先变成若干个group
然后呢我在group内部做简化
然后简化完之后呢
我去做简化
把它再分成cluster
这里面一个很重要的一点是说
我分成l o d e的
比如说我假设在l o d0
我有2000个cluster对吧
l l o d e的话
2000个cluster
比如说我们十个cluster
一个group
我有200个group
对不对
诶
我在l o d一的时候
我有1000个cos
对不对
那我这个时候呢
还是用一比十的比例把它变成了
比如说啊100个group
但注意这里面100个group和那个两
以前那个200个group
它的边界是不保证是一致的
这也是它最核心的一个思想
为什么呢
这样就保证了什么呢
保证了就是当它在l o d切换的时候
你看不到一个持续存在的一个boundary
那个boundary
否则的话就会一直出问题
好那这个东西是不是很复杂对吧
来我们的课程组的小伙伴
也发挥了我们的这个土法炼钢的神功
我们就开始用not a的算法
来去做了一个实验
我们拿可爱的班尼做了个实验对吧
这是一个bunny
那用nt的算法
你会发现诶他生成了这么多的claer对吧
这个看上去
这些每个coser大概是100多个三角形
128个三角形诶
下一步干什么事情呢
我们把caster把它聚类成一个gp
大家注意到这个课件上
那个红色的那个区域
那就是呃大概是十几个哦
16个cluster给18coser是吧
我们变成了一个coser group
然后呢我们对这个coser group进行一次简化
那么按照课程中的那个按照那个原文的话
你可以发现
就是一开始是那个秘密的cluster对吧
然后呢我们把class cop融合在一起去
对于整个功夫进行了一次简化
简化完之后呢
我们再run一次classroom
你会发现得到了一些新的cluster对吧
而这些新的cluster呢
和老的cluster之间的话
实际上是不再是一一对应
而是是说在这个l o d e里面的
这个class group的所有的cluster
可能和d0 里面这个class都是有关系的
因为这些三角形被reuse了
唉这个结构就会非常复杂了
这其实也是nana的
大家特别容易弄混的一件事情
就class group到底是什么东西好
你有了这个group之后呢
你会发现就是他为什么要这么做呢
其实啊
他希望每一个每一次这个group的boundary
在不同的l o d里面
因为group boundary是什么
在做l d的是什么
需要它的边的精度是要锁住的
大家还记得吗
他一定要锁住那个边
那么他希望这个被锁住的边啊
在每一层lo d的时候
它都会变换掉
这个很像什么东西呢
哎我自己一个土法炼钢
就是说很像你在做这个
比如说做这个三破零的时候
你比如说你做那个呃screen space ao的时候
你的采样那个r的分布
你每个pixel你希望他做一次接触
如果你不做杰train的话
你会发现你这个noise是很有pattern的对吧
你会注意到那个pattern
但其实他在这个几何采样的时候
他对他每一层的l o d的时候
他是强迫的把这个boundary做了一次gl three
所以使得你当这个几何在进行l o d调
就是随着你的相机的移动
它的l o d在不停的popping popping切换的时候
你没办法定死住
一个
就是说诶
一个你能注意到的一个高频的数据
因为那个高频的区域
在每一层l t变化的时候
它都会发生变化
这样你人眼就注意不到这样的一个
清晰的这样一个锁边的boundary
它实际上我我用最土的方法去理解
就是他就接触
但这个方法说句实话
我认为是非常非常巧妙的
真的很巧妙
那么这里面的话呢
所以这里面的话
这个图是很多人会弄混的一件事情
就是这张图实际上不是classer boundary
它是classer group的boundary
比如说红色的表达的是他的l o d0 的
所有的class group boundary
哎当我这些group里面做简化
然后呢我再去做classroom
然后呢我再去跑一次grp的时候
我可能得到的是这些绿色的这一层
你会发现绿色的这个边界
好像和那个红色的那一层就没有关系了
对不对
那我们再往上走一层
诶
那我到l o d r的时候
我这个class group就越来越大
那么它呢
实际上和这个就形成了这样一个套接关系
这个图的话呢
实际上是理解nana的几何的基础的一个
非常核心的一张图
也就是你会发现它这个用一个
非常巧妙的方法
把这个我们以前在做l o d
这个transition的时候
要左边的这个挑战给它彻底的给它解决掉
那么在这里面特别容易混淆的是说
他这里面展示的不是cluster
而是cluster group
好
那我们有了这样的一个表达的时候呢
原作给了这样的一张图
就是说你看我们基于这个
我们构建了这样一个漂亮的deck
deck是什么
deck就是一个有向无环图对吧
但是你们看这个deg
是不是不像一个复杂的这个有向无环图
更像是一棵树对吧
所有人看到这个都觉得哦
这个这个就是我基于这个class group
我去merge的时候
那这里面每个节点它到底是这个啊
到底是cluster呢还是cluster gp呢
对吧
其实这里面画的每个东西它是一个cluster
但是class之间的关系
它这个图画的实际上是有问题的
因为你到了l o d一到d2 的话
它的连接不应该是那么干净
实际上它的连接是非常非常复杂的
所以呢我们课程组呢
基于我们翻看了源代码
我们画出了我们的版本的这个图
它为什么是个deg
而不是tree
实际上这个图应该长的是这个样子
就是说首先大家看l d0
它下面的是同一个颜色
它其实表达的是在l o d0 里面
一个class group里面所有的cluster对吧
比如说红色的那些class group
蓝色组的class group
那个绿色组的class group
然后呢当你对它class group进行简化
你就可以得到了l o d e的那些cluster
然后呢在l o d e的那个coser呢
你会发现
当你再去run一次这个古品算法的时候
它实际上会和以前的l o d0 的那个
cluster功夫的关系是打乱的
你会发现我们用每个框表达一个class group的话
那实际上你会发现比如说在l d e的时候
左边这个classroom里面
它有一些cluster
指向的是这个红色区的cluster 0 level 0对吧
有些是指向
有一个是指向蓝色
就是那个蓝色的class那个group 0
那么在另外一个侧的class group里面的话呢
它也是这样去指的
所以这一张图的话实际上是none night
最重要的这张dg这个图
其实如果大家对这个图不理解的话
你后面他几乎所有的算法都很难理解
这个图我可以讲我们课程组吵了三天三夜
昨天夜里两点钟我还在电话
那个我们在视频会议里面
大家还在吵架
说中文到底是怎么回事
今天早上一时兴起打开源代码
一通看完
终于把他看明白对吧
这简直是个神坑
因为这张图说实话
画的绝对让大家很confuse
这他妈到底是为啊
这为什么一定是个dg
这很明显看上去是个数吗
但实际上的话呢
这一层层的cluster之间的连接的话
其实是这样的关系
这里面的话呢你可以看到乱中有序
首先是乱
就是说他l不同层的l o d之间的这个
caster之间链接啊
是多对多的链接
对不对
它就是每一个底层的cluster
他可能有multiple parents对吧
就是他上一集有多个
那么同时的话呢它有趣的地方在哪里呢
你会发现他虽然说它的parents可能是多个
但是他不会和上一集的所有的这个
同一级的coser都会建立
这种就是parent的关系
它只和由我自己做简化
就是simple带上去的那几个cluster有关系
所以他的这个影响是一个在localized的对吧
那么这个的话呢
就是说是一个很重要的一个系统
很重要的一个结构
你有了这个数据结构之后
你就能理解他后面的l o d是怎么做的
哎这张图大家一定要记得
我们后面还会再出现一次呢
大家不用着急
好好
那这个时候呢
我们还是拿我们可爱的班尼做案例
你会发现这就是我们课程所拿到的算法
去跑了一遍
你看l o d0 的时候
class我就切成这样了
那我们到l o d e的时候
按l d2 来
我们跳了几局啊
你看见这个classr已经变成这个样子了对吧
那他l d4 的时候一class这么大
到最后那个l d的时候
它大概是128个
就是那个班里就变成这个样了
所以呢
其实这就说明了他的那个原来的这张图
的解释啊
是对的
就这张图也就是说它每一集的classer
这个boundary确实一直在变
class group boundary
所以你不会就是当我们在这些cluster
来回切换的时候
你不会注意到一个consistent的那个bdi
让你注意得到哎
这就是拿来它是一个很巧妙的一个东西
但是呢这个漂亮的架构呢
实际上你要去维护它
是这个非常复杂的这个deck对吧
这个deck我去做l d怎么做
是不是很复杂
所以呢接下来就进入none night
第二个我认为比较难懂
大家特别容易computer的一个地方好
那这里面有个细节
就是这也是我对原作者
非常震惊的一个地方
就是他花了很多笔墨
讲了他怎么做这个simplification
对吧
当然我我觉得他讲这个也是有道理的
其实我个人一直认为就是mesh supplification
但是呢确实他讲了一件事情
我认为是对的
就是说如果你想实现not net的算法的话
你对他这个error的计算一定要准确
因为你的l r计算一旦不准确的话
当你的相机推来推去的时候
你可以注意到就是noticeable的这个poppy
当然他他要保证
就是每一次我的error都是subpixel
而且呢其实他后面还提了一个要求
就是我需要它每一层error往上去传递的时候
必须是单向累加的
这个累加其实是非常就这个单向增加的
这个单调性取值也是非常重要的一个设定
我们待会儿再去讲
ok但这个地方的话
我觉得这是我们课程组做的一个案例
就是说他是你是首先生成的classer
它把这个class之间通过链接关系呢
生成了一个graph
然后呢用mice这个中间件把它聚类成了group
然后呢一个grp里面的话呢
我用这个就是simplification方法
基于这个q e们呢
就是那个这个这个codrick的
那个error metric的这个方法诶
我对它进行了一个简化
简化之后呢
我又对它进行classroom对吧
我又可以形成我新的部分
它大概是这么一个pipeline
好
那有意思的问题就来了
我既然已经构建了这一个看起来有点像树
它又不像数的这么一个
deck的这么一个结构对吧
所有的classer从l d0
l d e l d r l的adn全部构建起来了
我的软碳
我给了你一个相机位
我怎么去选择它的这个l o d level
这个问题其实还是蛮挑战的
那么如果我们现在用view dependent的方法
我们去去做它的这个level的话
就是说我们最简单的做法
就是我在这个deck里面去从它的根节点
因为它这个代表到最后的根节点
是一个cluster
你去看看源代码
你就知道就是他最后发现诶
我的cho只是只能生成一个
只有一个cluster的这样的一个case
说我的这个合并就停止了
好那我知道他的error对吧
我就根据我的view
我就不停的问我的error够不够不够
我就往下走
就是说我实际上呢
他把这些同一个cluster group的东西
做成了一个大的虚拟节点
整个这个节点有一个error
有个绑定
那实际上我是不是就可以知道说哎
我对这个group我是不是可见啊
是不是需要被cut掉
如果不要不需要被cut掉的话
我继续绘制它
但是这样的一个dg啊
你去traverse
他的话是不是还是比较费的
比较复杂的对吧
就是大家想想
这个算法写起来有一点头疼了
对不对
那么好
作者在这边的话呢
提出了一个很重要的思想
就是说首先他认为你的这些cluster
如果都属于一个group的话
如果我这个caster group如果要往下去绘制的话
那所有人如果选了l o d0
那我所有的cluster in the same grou
都要被画成l o d0 对吧
如果我不是l o d0
那我就不画
这个想法其实很淳朴
我认为也是可以理解的
这个问题不大
这样的好处是什么呢
就是它的l o d的选择是比较快的
但是真正最难理解的是什么呢
就是说实际上所有的l o d问题
你在这样的一个类树状的结构里面
你其实找的还是那一条的cut line对吧
那么这个cut line的话
你想啊我们真实的一个几何
比如像我们做的那个dragon那个例子里面啊
那个例子里面大概将近有1万多个吧
1万多个这个caster
那我把这1万多coser
以及它构建的那一层层的lled结构
我把它整个traverse一遍的话
大家觉得这个速度是不是会非常的慢
那大家想个办法说
我能不能让我的这个l o d的selection
全部的并行化
也就是每一个单位
每一个啊指数或者每一个节点
他自己决定我在当前的l o d下
我到底是绘制还是不绘制对吧
比如像这个图像里面
就是说那条被黄线勾中的那些顶点
就是我要绘制的
没有被各种
我就不绘制对吧
那这样的一条cut line的话
他最好是deterministic的诶
这个就是对于这种dg的这个结构啊
大家会发现
如果你真的假设
你对他的不做一个单调性的约束的话
你这个数从左向右便利对吧
从上向下深度遍历对吧
或者从右向左边离
你
在数学上
你会发现它有可能这个cut是不稳定的
那么如果这个cut是不稳定的话
你知道会出现什么情况吗
大家还记得我在我在前面讲了
那个那个算法的时候
就是说他可能会出现the fighting啊
popping啊
就是说诶你的camera没动对吧
这一帧和那一帧算法上
只是因为那个就是b型化的这个计算
它提交的这个先后顺序有
那么这个
这个这个就是亿万分之1ms的区别
导致了他们的数据就fight了
fight之后这个结果就不一样了对吧
那所以他就希望说唉我的这个决策的话
同时的话呢它的结果必须是deterministic的
那怎么去做这件事情呢
这也是none night
我觉得很重要的一个点
就所以我这个标题我自己优化过的
就是我觉得如何paralyzation
第一个呢他要求这个deg树上的这个error
它是单调性的往上涨
因为如果你的单调性的往上涨的话呢
你给我任何一个error sours hold
他的这条cut线一定是唯一的
哎这个在数学上大家可以去证明一下对吧
第二件事情是什么呢
就是说到底每一个节点
它到底是怎么样的决定
我是否可见的话
它实际上呢你从树的根节点往下去
便利自然是一个解法
但是呢你这个数的便利的话
其实你很难把它做的并行化
但是他后面其实有个方法并行化
待会儿再讲啊
但是这个并行化的话很麻烦
那他想了一个方法
就是说其实你要的东西是什么呢
对于任何一个节点
他要被渲染
其实要满足两个条件对吧
第一个条件呢
就是说我的我的父亲的那个节点
他的error要大于你给定的这个threshold
对吧
同时呢我自己的这个coser
我的error要小于和等于的
那意味着我这个caster是可见的
所以说其实我并不需要把这个树上的
所有的节点
按照你的那个顺序就是遍历一遍
就一定我并不一定要按照从root往下便利
其实我把这所有的节点全部拍平
看成一个列表
我就用这个方程去验证一遍了
假设我每个节点会存一下
我父亲的arrow的话
实际上我就可以把一个数的traverse
变成一个raid traverse
这个这个地方是有点抽象了
但大家一定要理解
因为你不理解这个的话
它这个地方其实核心的想法是什么呢
就是说这样就使得每一个节点的l o d的
decision能够并行化的进行
否则的话
我就必须要按照数的结构去访问它
那按照数字结构访问它
随着你的树的深度的话
我的访问的效率就会下降对吧
如果我并行的话
我一次可以32 30个往里面扔的话
我的效率是不是更高
对不对
这就是它的一个核心的想法
而且呢在这里面还有一个细节是说
在这一颗带给里面
他去做这个l o d selection的单位到底是什么
是每个卡cluster自己做这个我的检测呢
还是以cluster grp为单位
那我接下来会讲这个细节
这个细节也是特别容易混淆的
实际上呢
我们看到它的代码是以claser group为单位
但是呢又精准到每一个cluster
但是它核心的想法就是每一个检测
它都是isolated的
其实在这个它的这个数里面
它存储的呢
就是他其实这个时候已经不需要输了对吧
他其实把每一层l o d0
l o d e这里面的cast group变成一个节点
这个节点它可以拍平
但是每一个节点呢它存两组数据
第一组数据呢是我的parents对吧
比如说我假设我的l o d里面
这个group是有四个caster组成的
我把它四个简化成两个的话
那我这个简化过程中产生的最大的erro
就是我的parent error
我存在这假如parent error是1.2放在这
然后呢我自己本身的话
比如说l o d0 的话
它实际上是没有l的
对不对
但是呢你哪来的
实践中
它有一个小trick
它会把这个强制制成-1对吧
很有意思
他就好mark一下
就是说你看我这个是绝对正确的一个几何
但是这不重要
反正是他的细节
他就往上这样做
但是核心反正-1比零小嘛
所以没有问题对吧
那么好对于那个在l o d一里面
大家可以看到有两个cluster
一个是红色的
一个是那个绿色的
那其实呢它也会存一个我的paraerror
和我们这个cluster
因为我行过来的话
我各自的error你会发现
就是说它们源自于同一个
就是低级的l o d group of class group的话
他两个简化过了caster
虽然它们分属于不同的l o d一级的
classroot了
它的error两个class error是一模一样的
诶这个是很重要的一点
就是他们在做网上合并进行简化
即使简化完之后
即使分成两个不同的coser
它的error都是取得这次简化过程中
产生的最大的error
好那这样的话我这就意味着什么呢
就这里面在这张图里面
假设我的输入是threshold的一点
这个ao你不能超过我对吧
诶我对于这三个cluster group对吧
有两个是属于l o d1
有一个是属于l0
我怎么去计算呢
哎很简单
首先我检测第一个条件就是我的parent error
要大于我的这个ths hold
你会发现这三个cluster都满足你的需求
对吧
我的在lv 0的时候
parent是1.1没有问题
你大于一了
第二个呢led的那个就是那个蓝红色
那个l d一里面的那个红色的class group呢
他的partnl是1.2更大了对吧
因为往上以及它会变得更大了
好
你也满足了
那个绿色的那个l o d e的cluster
他也满足了
他是1.4
好都没问题
好我们再看下一个问题
诶
这个地方的话其实是原来pp
就我觉得这块写的不算严谨
应该叫for each cluster in the class group
你的cast error如果小于等于ths hold的时候
哎
我这个时候
我认为这个cluster就可以被渲染
但是对于我们这里面给的这个案例里面
比如说在红色里面
那个1.1的那个黄色的那个
就是那个红色那个l l o d y
l o d e的那个class group里面的话
那个1.1等于l的group
他还是不满足这个条件
所以它的下面的那个class group
那个它这个东西就不会被绘制对吧
那么对于那个绿色的l o d e的
那个class group来讲呢
在l d里面它也一样不满足
所以那个紫色的class group也不会给大家
这个大家就会去想了
说因为我不会被绘绘制
所以呢我要激活我的children的这个class
对不对
但其实这个地方如果你这么想的话
就意味着你没有理解这个并行化的这个
l o d selection
实际上每个class group里面的每个classer
他只是做自己的检测
就是相当于是说我那个红色的框class group面
假设有四个class的话
他每个cluster只是自己决定说我是否会制
但是因为我不会制
所以我需要我的child这个哦
我的下一集的那个l o d0 的那个东西
绘制的话
这个决策跟我没有关系
但是呢因为我的这个error
他严格的网上传递的话
当你做到那个l o d0 里面
那个绿色的卡斯库的时候
它的数据上一定会满足
说他的paraerror是1.1大于一点的
这个sal的
但是呢他自己的error的话
应该是-1小于那个一点
所以他这些就是d0 里面的四个小classer
全部会被绘制一点
唉这一点是特别特别容易混淆的
就是大家会天然的认为是说诶
我的上一级的l o d发现没通过
我就看我的下一集
其实它不是的
他把整个这个树的结构全部拍平了
哪个class不是我自己处理
当然你会发现
就是只要你保证这个error的话
是严格的单调的网上传递
而且我下一集的那个parent error
一定是跟上一集那个对应的cluster的
那个自己的error是严格一致的话
你会发现这个测试出来的结果
是严格一致的
不会出问题
而且几何不会去渲染两次
这其实是作者一个非常核心的一个
一个想法
这个想法非常的巧妙
实话实说非常的巧妙
也就是说
因为以前当我们在做一些l o d的时候
我们会天然的会做一个树状结构嘛对吧
那我们对这个l o d树的这个处理的话
天然的就会树状的一次一次下去
但是的话not net这里面的话
他因为意识到
就现在gpu的b型化处理能力非常强
他就希望把这个o d的selection
变成彻底的b型化的处理
所以很遗憾在这个原原始的这个ppt中的话
这个作者把这个事情就是
几乎是一一笔带过
nana的技术的时候
会发现这一part是非常非常难以理解的
而且它的源代码中写的是叫club
这个叫class error
小于s的对吧
但其实他是class功夫里面存的是paraerror
但是呢它这个功夫里面的话有一组cluster
所以每个coser自己会称自己的error
他要所以说这个比较的话是在鼓舞里面
每个l自己去比较的
然后呢各个class group的l o d的selection
就是我到底是绘制还是不会知道
但是你会发现它最终的结果一定是对的
这也是not net非常巧妙的一个地方
好这个给给他那个点赞的时间
差不多到此结束了
就不点他的赞了
好那么实际上的话呢
这就是它的整个基于class group的构建了
这样的一个hy的这样一个结构
我可以b进化的决定他的similar那个d
但是呢诶作者的第二排就来了
我觉得这样虽然我还是可以并行化的做
但是毕竟class的数量太多了
而且呢我的cluster的这个这个
这个数量还是很大
这时候作者就提出了一个很很牛逼的一
个想法
在这个他的自己的报告中的话
整个这个东西是在一个页面下的
很小的一块
说我构建了一个b v h4 对吧
把所有的children的这个l r全部maximum在一起
然后呢
所有的l o d ection了
我的天哪
这么复杂的一个算法
老人家用三句话就讲完了
当时哈我自己读到这一趴的时候
我就觉得啊这真的是太难理解了
对吧
然后又是被逼着我们课程组的小伙伴
又开始钻进代码里面一通狂搞狂研究
然后就就去仔细理解这个我们的原作者
他这个b vh到底是怎么构建呢对吧
这个地方我确实要小小的吐槽一下
就是这个presentation确实是没讲清楚
但是我猜可能是有意的吧
这么高深的算法
怎么可能让我们这种凡人学会呢
那没办法
凡人也是要修仙呢
所以凡人也是很努力的去理解先人的想法
其实这个想法的核心是什么呢
唉这是我们课程组自己画的图啊
这个也有
我真的要给我们课程组点赞
就是说其实啊这个bbs是非常的抽象
但是呢他它的实际的情况是这样的
就是说对于这条龙而言
那其实你如果你的l o d0 所形成的
所有的class group
对不对
那么你可以把所有l o d0 的class group
用一个bbs的方法形成一颗tree诶
那同样呢对于你的l o d一所有的cast group
你是不是也可以形成一个bh tree对吧
那么l o d一直到l o d n它都能形成bh
然后呢他把这些所有的tree的节点诶
把它连到一个共同的根节点
它就构建了一个超级的b vh tree
他为什么要做这样一件事情呢
这个事情其实是有很深的道理的
就是前面我一直在讲这个
这也是作者
我觉得一方面大谈这个诶
我的l o d selection
我要paralyzation
但是他又意识到
就是说
但其实你只要处理的class grp
数量实在太大了对吧
那举一个例子
比如像这条龙
它有700万个三角形
那我会生成11万个cluster对吧
group的
那么group的数量也是几万个
那我每一次在一个camera的情况下
我要把这个啊其实比11万还要
比那个就是1万多还要多
因为你是1万多个
假设一比十的换算
一比11000个
cluster group在four l o d0 的话
那你再往上l d一是多少
是5000多个对吧
l d2 是2000多个
把你这个二的密大概是2万多个
这个class group对吧
你把这个数据就是即使你用并行的方法
把它paralyzation一下
这个效率其实也是很低的呀
啊作者这时候突然意识到原来不香啊
就是这个这个traverse
一个array的数据是很不香的
那怎么办呢
哎传统艺能来了
我们给他把这些所有因为每个class group
你可以想象成一小片几何吗
它有那个绑定嘛对吧
那这个在空间上的物体块
而且大小都差不多
那我最优的组织方式是什么呢
我把它升成b vh嘛对吧
而且b vs里面的它这个error的话
我可以取他的这个绑定
我可以取他们的和诶error
我取它们的最大
这样的话
当我的相机看到一个就是一个cluster
一个一个一个一个物体的时候
比如说对r o d0
他跟这个物体如果距离我很远
他这个那个绑定的话
离我最近的地方可能距离我可能10米对吧
然后呢
l o d0 上它最大的l也是-1对吧
那整个这棵树就这1万多个class grp
我是不是完全不用traverse了
对不对
作者真的是大聪明啊
这个地方它突然又意识到树的好处了
那好我这个这个地方这1万多个class gp 9
我就不用看看了
那同理l o d1
如果10米之外
你可以把整个这个l o d e的这个
这个class groups全部cut掉对吧
那你可能到l o d7 的时候
你发现这个error我需要notifine
然后呢你平时在里面去traverse了
所以说其实啊怎么说呢
他这个时候这个思想就比vh的话
实际上又引入了
就是我们以前在做这种with bility的时候
经常用的这个方法
但这个方法有没有道理呢
我个人觉得
虽然我这个觉得他讲得实在是太过分了
对吧
就这几句话
但是呢我个人认为
这个方法其实对于nt来讲非常的关键
因为确实对于这么高精度的几何的话
如果你即使把所有的coser group traverse一遍
这件事情
它的负载也是惊人的
想想你场景有那么多的物体怎么办对吧
所以的话呢它构建这个b vs b vs tree的话
对性能的影响非常大
但是这里面为什么它可以就是不用l o d
01234构建了一个tree
它反而把零的节点认成一个税一的节点
一个成一个睡
实际上这个考虑是很聪明的
为什么呢
对于很多时候
这个物体啊离我的距离可能有点远
比距离我5米
距离我10米
有的时候距离我20米
对不对
这个距离在游戏场景里面不算很远对吧
但是很可能你的cluster group
数量最多的那个case
那么多
卡斯可以全部不用traverse直接给剃掉
所以那一棵树整个就被踢掉了
所以说这个呢
实际上是作者一个非常聪明的方法
但是呢确实实话实说
就是在它的原作中没有讲清楚对吧
所以我们课程组绞尽脑汁的时候
把这张图画出来了
同学们就明白了
那这里面特别容易confuse的东西是什么呢
这是啊
其实我们把它那个
整个那个树都给倒出来了对吧
你会发现他把这些所有的这些l o d的
这些group全部构建成一棵树
它还有一个小trick
就是说诶我我尽可能build一个
就是说这个这个张度为四的这样的一棵树
它其实做这个大家如果以前学过数据结构
就学学过叫树的那个平衡嘛
我把树原来不平衡的数
把它变成平衡数对吧
否则的话这样让我的这个这个数的便利
尽可能的效率高一点
但这里面有一个有一个细节
就是说在他这个b vs树
树的这个叶节点里面
挂的是一个个的classer group
不是一个个的cluster
这也是一个大家很注意的一点
但这个点呢大家如果讲错了
大家也可以去查一下
反正我们是花了很多力气
去研究它的源代码
去看待这件事怎么做的好
那其实呢你有了这样的一个结构的话
实话实说
这里面也是他的自己的一个demo对吧
这是600万个三角形的一个一个case
那么它会合成多少呢
大概会合成这个就11万cluster
那么如果我们当我们构建了b y h的话
实际上我们大概只check了107个
比vh nose
你看从11万变成107
然后呢我们只需要去check 4000多个class
这比11万几乎少了
将近有大概有20多倍吧
将近二三十倍左右
然后呢你最后可见的大概是2000多个
所以这回让这个算法变得真正的可以实战
所以之前我刚才讲的
就是说b y h这个东西的话呢
对于nt来讲
其实是个很关键性的一步
如果他不做这个的话
只用我们上一节就上一章讲了
这个算法的话
其实他实战中的效率是很低的
所以我认为这个事情也是很关键的一步
那么接下来呢就是原作者是大谈特谈的
就特别得意的说
哎呀我有了个b bh对吧
我怎么去traverse
他呢
他说哎呀传统的方法对吧
我就在这棵树
我就一层层的去traverse
第一层把根节点扫一遍
产生很多新的子节点子节点
然后呢我扔到新的任务thread里面
我再去跑
然后呢再形成第二层
第三层它是这个方法特别的慢
那怎么办呢
哎它实现了一个小小的类似于这种
那个就是job system
大家记得我们在前面那个d o p job sister
讲的
就是说诶我把很多的walking thread固定下来
然后呢我是用一个pmc的方法
就是multiproducer muli consumer的结构
然后呢
就是说我在我产生了任何一个子节点
我就直接扔到一个我的task q里面
那现在这个walking read里面只要有个thread空呢
他就把这个q把这个任务捡起来
他就处理掉了
就是一堆人往后面opending任务
一堆人的用前面的指针去取任务对吧
就是这个这其实是一个很简单的一个结构
当然了
因为它要依赖于现在的这个显卡
就是这个computer shor
它其实可以实现
就是叫多很多个working read
之间可以共享一个p对吧
它可以实现这种原子化的这个锁定
所以能做这件事
实话实说呢
作者在这个这个报告中
大谈特谈的这个这个这个设计
但是我个人觉得
这就是一个实现了一个小trick
然后呢大概大概实现了10%到
他说10%到30左右的acceleration对吧
但实际上其实我觉得他比bh
是它最核心的一个思想
但是的话呢
就是我们的traverse
速度会变得稍微快那么一丢丢
而且这个方法呢
我个人觉得大家如果理解了
什么是job system的话
你可以理解成
就是说我在这个就是computer shor上
利用那个compusher
他一次性发出32个walking read的
这个设计的话
把它32个threat
我可以re全部固定住
然后呢做一个公共的task buffer啊
那个就是to be handle task buffer
然后呢我这头往里面扔入啊
这头往后面ending任务
那一头呢取任务就好了
两个指针就完事儿对吧
所以的话呢
这个啊是一个作者的一个小的trick
我个人觉得应该比较好理解
那么这样的话讲到这一part
我觉得none night最复杂的几何的表达
终于就讲完了
我不知道同学们有没有听懂啊
如果大家听不懂的话
我们会再想办法对吧
我们还有二零系列的课程
对不对
虽然我每次跟我的团队讲
二零系的
可能大家都会说
求不要再做二零系列的课程
实在太累了对吧
ok那我们先把这个坑留在这儿吧
那么好
那有了这样的几何的时候
接下来我们讲讲nmt到底怎么渲染
它想渲染之前呢
先讲一个他自己特别引以为傲的东西
就是nmt
我们去做rts ation
那为什么要去这个russell zation呢
其实nana
如果达到这么精细的一个几何密度啊
它其实很多三角形
已经和屏幕上的像素差不多大了
那么如果跟屏幕上像素差不多了
那我三角形的绘制到屏幕上
我们用的方法是什么
诶我们用的是这个硬件的ross rozation
对吧
大家传统我觉得硬件的ross应该是最快的
肯定比我自己写设计点快了啊
确实是这样
但是呢其实硬件的reservation的话呢
实际上它有一个假设
首先在硬件中为了处理
我们在做这个texture sampling
你们的dx d d y
他每一次rose rozation的话呢
它一般至少会rose rise
就是2x2的pixel
这样我才能算出它d d x d y
第二个呢就是run的算法呢
它是一个高度优化过的算法
就是在古典时代啊
我们的三角形都很大
那么我们去对这个三角形进行
扫描的时候呢
我们用的一般用的是skyline算法
那其实呢如果我是一个像素
就一行像素
一行像素skline的话呢
这个计算其实非常的费
大家如果想想就知道了
那怎么办呢
我们就想到了一个聪明的方法
我们说把屏幕按4x4
分成一个个的套对吧
我首先检测说这个skyline
是不是在这个town里面
那如果这个skyline不在这个town里面的话
整个topixel我不用检测
这其实也是古典时代呢
大家意识到
就是说诶
三角形的数量是远远低于屏幕的pixel的数量
就可以快速的
这是cut掉很多
我不需要去进行计算的这些pixel对吧
但是呢这个大聪明的这个
到了我们的这个
当这个船狗已经小到跟皮克斯差不多的时
候
问题就来了
因为在这个nt里面
我很多三角形其实已经是接近于一个pixel了
我的天呐
我为了去渲染你这一个pixel大小的三角形
我要去这个访问
我要generate 16倍的pixel去做他的realization
这上有大量的计算是被浪费掉了
那这个时候怎么办呢
哎我们就想到了一个方法
就是拿来的方法就是说诶我们用software方法
rose rise
只是说他用了computer shader
他就直接把这个小三角形的rust rization
它自己全部接管对吧
这样的话呢
他自己就就是now night的这个software sation
它自身是比硬件的要快三倍
那怎么去rts其实也是比较简单的
就是说首先的话
如果这个三角形本身小于一个pixel的话
他啥也没干
他就啪打一个pixel上去就完事了
这个显然比那个skyline要好
这个快很多对吧
否则的话那个是sky
先在16x4x4的
16个pixel里面先算一遍
然后最后抓到说哦
原来是这个黄色的pix又被点亮
那单身的话呢
nana因为你知道每个三角形的边长和面积嘛
所以你就知道它投影上面它就是一个pixel
啪就丢上去了
对不对
所以它会非常的快
然后呢
因为你知道
每一个就是这个三角形的vertex
所以你其实可以根据vertex上存的这个uv
可以算出它的dd x d y
你不用去做一个2x2的pixel
对吧好
那么它的原则是什么呢
其实是个很high的一个数据
但是我觉得这个数据
其实可能是他的经验数据
就是说对于每一个首先的话
对于每个cluster
如果这里面三角形的所有的边长
就是他在投影情况下
它都少
rust rization都小于16个spring pixel的话
他就把整个这个cluster切换到software ross
zation的这样的一个这个pipeline里面去
那么反之
如果这个cluster离我比较近
这里面的有三角形
它超过了18个pixel的边长的话
那我怎么办呢
哎我还是交给传统的这个hardware pipeline
但这个我后面再讲
那这里面有一个很大的一个一个挑战
就是说我去写computer shader
写一个software rather rise pipeline
其实是比较简单的一件事对吧
我就把这个像素的点填好就行了
这个sky算法其实也比较简单
就是算两头
对于每一行的pixel算两头
我就知道中间这一排点我全部要填
但是大家知道就是在我们做哪来的
这么复杂的几何的时候
它其实很多几何会做的
那么在传统的管线中呢
我们有个机制叫early z
就是说如果z bar里面这个东西它已经有了
那我就不用再做了
对不对
那么我其实就算没有
lz我总要做z testing吧
software rose riser的话
他怎么去能够
early的把这个东西给干掉呢
这里面它就有一个有一个trick了
他怎么办呢
他利用了一个扩展的sdk
就是他直接写了一个64位的
这样的一个原子形的操作
然后呢
他在这里面用了一个interlock max的这个算子
就是说他把深度写到这个
64位数字的高位
那意味着什么
就你后面所有的这个buffer的这些信息
比如说你是哪个cluster呀
你是哪个triangle啊
这数据随便你写
没关系的
但是只要你的depth比他大
那其他的depth肯定就会被干掉了
对不对
所以说其实呢他用了这个
就是这个其实是一个trick了
但是我觉得这个trick的话呢
实际上在未来的意见中肯定要支持的
就是说当我去写sofa rose rise的时候
诶
我自己手动的模拟了一下
模拟了一下the testing的这样一个过程
所以这个是它的一个trick
但是呢这样的一个trick的话呢
实际上我就能够把那些就是说被挡住的
那些几何全部给它过滤掉对吧
那么这个时候你可以看到它
它在这三个维度
你可以看到它的生成的depth对吧
生成的这个class的i d
然后呢它生产的全过id
这都是用伪彩色把那个id表达出来了
大家可以看到就是非常的有意思对吧
claer其实就算是clar也是非常的密
那三角形几乎就已经达到
像素级别的东西了
那么这里面就隐含了给大家讲了一件事情
就是nne他的shading啊
它在几何的这一趴深沉的东西
它其实是用visited
visibility buffer的方法去rendering的
他并不是上来直接生成了g8 分
而是说先把每个class的id
和这个传播的案例打出来
所以谁定的事情放在后面
他先把几何答对好
那么接下来的话呢
它lighting pass就跟我们刚才讲的visibi barender
一样的对吧
就是我拿到了阴森的id了
拿到传一个id了
我就把你三个vertex index找到
把vertx的数据position什么全部拿到
我就拿到你的这个什么
根据你的那个每个vertex的uv啊
我进行插值
然后我就算出你的这个啊
你的那个ab do啊
你的这个spacer这些东西
大家可以发现我们前面为什么要跟大家讲
vc b g visibility buffer based rendering
其实这就是大家去理解nlight
它核心上面一个关键的block对吧好
那这个时候就是拿来的这个方法好
那你有了这样一个东西的话
其实大家就像经常讲的
就是我们觉得这个算法是不是会非常的费
啊对吧
因为你你想这里面要写这么多东西
其实会非常的对
但实际上的话呢你会发现
就是说作者说在现代的gpu情况下
其实是在这个那个console主机上
也都实现了
他说其实不像大家想的那么废
我就我个人还是很愿意相信这个结论
那么这里面有个很重要的一点
就是刚才我们在前面讲了
visibility buffer based rendering
讲的就是说
其实对于一个真正的现代游戏引擎
来讲的话
那我们还是会建议
就是说你要把维斯的buff和deer的renderer
设定结合在一起
为什么呢
因为你有很多的物体走的还是default
rendering对吧
那你这个时候的话呢
你增加一个mature pass
同样去写他的g8 分的话
这样的话你后面的lighting pass的
整个papi全部是统一的
否则的话你要除以两遍
如果大家去看那个就是说啊
比如说像aya那个就是曼哈顿那个demo里面
就是matrix那个那个demo的话
实际上它不是所有的几何都走nt
只有部分几何走的是nt
很多绝大部分几何走的还是传统的低分的
这个就是differ的papi
但这两种东西的渲染的话
本身毫无压力地混合在一起了
这也是本身我觉得他很聪明的一个地方
因为其实not net只能解决那些静态的结合啊
那对于这种动态的
比如说character角色呀
奔跑的汽车呀对吧
就是他是让nana的目前的技术是解决不了的
好
那么这样的话呢
其实这里面大家注意到一点
就是not ne他去做这个rozation的话呢
它是以每一个cluster为单位
记住啊
不是class grp
是每个class为单位
就是根据刚才我讲的那个原则
就是他的如果所有的边都小于18个pixel
那怎么办
我就把整个class扔到这个sofrurider里面去
那如果是大于的话
那我这classroom没办法
我就扔给hardw
这张图中就是原作者给出来的
就是说诶那个红色的那些区域
就表示走的是hardw
你会发现绝大部分的区域走的全是software
resation
这也是非常了不起的一件事情
但这件事情呢我自己是很想多说一句
就是我觉得首先他想到用computer shader
做sofarrier是个很聪明的一个想法对吧
确实比现在传统硬件的实现效率高很多
但是我个人特别好奇的一件事情
就是说比如像nvidia amd对吧
他们看到了这个算法
如果是我的话
我肯定会在硬件上实现一套跟他比
他效率更高
而且不用你再去写写诗的方法
也就是你三角形
你告诉我说就是tiny triangle对吧
我走的就是一个非常高效的硬件的这个single
pixel的这种管线
那么所以的话呢我个人很好奇
就是说nvidia最新的
他提出的那个micromash的那个那个
那个那个那个功能的话
是不是就是把这个他的software rose riser
硬件化了一下
反正我如果我是mvd的话
我肯定会干这件事情对吧
所以有可能这些代码在未来
由硬件直接支撑了
可能不需要我们自己再去写
这么复杂的caitter shor来解决这个问题
好
那么作者也提到一件事情
就是很多的instance呢
他可能离你非常的远
因为大家意识到就是在真实的游戏场景中
比如说一个小雕像
它这么大
当我的相机凑近的时候对吧
我需要绘制它很多很多三角形
但是它如果我在我20米之外的话
其实它可能只占几个像素
那这个时候
即使我把它简化到最小的
128个船口
它也是本身也是不好那个精度过度的
而且呢你就像刚才我那个班尼的例子嘛
那个班尼我把它捡到了128个
那个就是那个那个chango的时候
你觉得那个还像是那个兔子吗
对不对
作者可能也意识到这件事情了
他怎么办呢
他又用到了我们的传统的神器叫做imposter
这个imposter是我们在做l o d的时候
一个很经典的算法
就是说我对于这些instance的话
诶我去进行12x12个
144个view进行采样
然后呢每个view下
我踩踩一个12x12个pixel的一张图
这个图里面的话呢
我会存什么东西存在的这个abel啊
存在的normal啊
甚至存在的深度啊
那这样的东西的话呢
实际上就是当我这个因此离我足够远的时
候
我的整个nana的管线都不启动
我直接把in post往上一扒
我的defs也是对的
我的d8 翻你的数据也是对的对吧
你后面的设定该怎么做就怎么做
其实我觉得这个方法其实说明啊
就是传统的这些lled的方法
其实在这么高级的现代管线里面
它还是有用的
还是实战的东西
所以这是nana他做rendering的这一part好
那么其实呢大家可以看到
就是说用了这样的一套体系啊
这个overdraw
但是实际上一个真实的拿到的场景
你可以看到就是那个红色高亮的区域
就是偶尔做比较费的
其实这里面他会讲的就是偶尔做啊
实际上还是非常的昂贵的
但是呢它对于整个这个nana的管线来讲
你不同的trango的尺寸
它的偶尔做的这个瓶颈是不一样的
比如说如果你是small triangle的话呢
其实你会发现因为你go再小
我都要去采集你三个顶点的数据对吧
要进进进进行这种差值啊
百30个codation的计算
然后还要去插值
要去采样
每个pixel我都得折腾这么一边
而且很多时候这个三角形如果过小的话
在一个pixel里面
可能好几个三角形叠到一起去了
那实际上我的vertext transformation
那个transform还triangle set up
其实是变得非常的慢
就是说我们在这个visibility buffer
后面的那一部叫jim concert
那个buff那一把是很废的
那么如果你三角形是个中不溜秋的话呢
其实你会发现就是pixel它在这个coverage的时候
他的肺是比较费
但是如果你全是很大的时候
他最废的是什么呢
大家还记得刚才我们讲的那个
我们自己hike了一个64个比特的
那个就是depth对吧
那个天杀就很高级
但是呢它其实是有一个叫原子性计算的
这个要求
那原子性计算有什么特点
就是我去写的时候
我去读读或者写的时候你就不要操
你就不要做操作了
那这样的话呢它会形成一个atomic bd对吧
所以这个呢实际上是就是那个啊
我们讲的就是说这一套他的rose rose方法的话
会产生的一些性能的问题
我相信在未来随着硬件的优化的话
很可能我们不需要像我刚才讲的那样的
我可能不需要自己去hike那个software arrier
我甚至可能不需要我自己去high一个自己的
z buffer的testing方法
因为换着我是n v d n n n m d的话
如果我相信这是未来的话
我肯定在硬件上给你解决了
对吧好吧
希望业界的发展
能够追上我们的引擎发展的步伐好
那最后一个呢呃也不是最后一个
接着讲
就是哎当我们有了这么多的几何
我们有了这样的buffer
接下来来了一个大家特别容易忽视的问题
就是说我到底怎么去给它贴上材质
那为什么这件事情很复杂呢
就是因为啊其实我们看到一个场景啊
就是在游戏里面看到一个场景
其实它是有很多很多的材质合成的对吧
每一种材质的话
它的texture它的数据都不一样
这里面这个例子
就是说你这样的一个nt的场景
这个是不同材质用伪彩色表达出来
你就意识到这个材质是不一样的对吧
那这么多的材质你怎么去绘制它呢
诶那none night
他想了一个方法
是这样的
他说呢
我把每个材质i d
把它变成一个depth的一个指值
这个就相当于说每个i d
它在这个在这个depth里的值是不一样的
然后呢他做一件什么事情呢
他就是我知道我屏幕上有多少种材质对吧
我每个材质绘制的时候
我把那个材质i d做个z testing
就是这里面this test呢它用的不是小鱼
也不是大于用的是什么
是等于就是说你的深度等于我的时候
你这些pixel我才去绘制
你就相当于是说每一个材质我扫过去
全屏的话
只有那些你的depth里面的那个呃mature
depth
等于我当前的材质id的这些pixel才会被绘制
哎你想想看这个事情的话呢
它既费有不废
说先费的地方
比如说我这个屏幕上有50种材质的话
意味着我for screen要扫50次
对不对
但是呢它不废的地方是什么呢
因为这50次里面它对于每个pixel来讲
它只能是指50种材质的一种
所以呢实际上我去那个非常复杂的做这个
这个做那个pixel shading的
就是大家知道在用的buff去渲染那个pixel
其实是很麻烦的
对不对
诶
我只会对于屏幕上的pixel的数量做一遍
所以呢早期的not night用的就是这个方法
但这个方法大家意识到有没有问题了
就是说假设我的镜头里面有上百种材质
那我就要渲染上百个full screen pass对吧
这件事情就算把这个屏幕上几百万个像素
做这个z testing
做这个50次
100次的话
这件事情的overhead
实际上并不像大家想的那么小
我记得以前跟今天跟大家讲
就是大家我们做particle的时候
最容易犯的错误是什么
就是我画了很多透明的cod
然后呢在相机的镜头叠他个几十个上百个
而且每一个都是全屏那么大
其实基本上都绘制没什么贡献
但是你会发现这个性能会下降的非常厉害
所以呢作者在最新的作品中
他就发现了这个问题
那现在的这个nana他是怎么做的呢
哎我这是我们最近在看的一个东西
就是说我为什么要把four screen qu
来进行处理呢
哎我们为什么不用tod base方法呢
这个方法是不是很淳朴对吧
大家还记得我们在讲tairender
其实也提到过类似的思路
它很简单
就是把屏幕分成很多个
64x64的这样的一套
那其实在每个top里面
它真正有的这个材质的数量不会那么多
对吧
那我怎么办呢
哎我假设用computer shader
把所有的ta我全部扫一遍
我先看讲这个啊
那我就可以得到一张表
这张表是什么呢
就是说首先我虽然理论上我有1000种
1万种material
但是对于我当前的这个screen来讲
可能只用了100种对吧
我每一个每一个材质呢
我们叫做一个material slot好
那每个match slot呢
我就在这个tale里面去检测
就是说这个tale里面只要有一个pixel
他是有这个材质的话
那我就把这个tab标记成啊
是yes
是一对吧
那我我用32个比特
就是我一个数字是不是可以表达32个
太阳里面
我这个材质是否可信
那我把屏幕上的这个
因为屏幕分辨率无非也就是1080对吧
或者是那个就是那个22k或者4k对吧
那你的太阳的数量是有限的嘛
那好那很简单
那我就就形成了一个array
就是对于每一种可见的材质
实际上我就生成了一个array
我就知道哪些tag里面
我这个材质需要处理的好
当我有了这样一张表之后
我接下来可以做一件什么事情呢
其实也就非常简单了
对于每一个材质
我用了一次indirect桌括
你看着我也是画了无数个tale
但是呢我可以在computer shader里面
把那些没有我这个材质的
这些tale全部给跳掉
唉你想这个事情是不是很聪明对吧
因为对于一种材质来讲
我只可能在部分的泰坦尼克见
那这样的话我一个桌括他
其实他每次呢是一批
一次性处理32个太阳对吧
然后呢他一个屏幕这样快速的扫一扫
扫一扫
虽然你看着这个桌廓比较复杂
但实际上它非常的快
因为最费的是一个一个的像素
他这样的话一次性64x60是多少
3000多个像素点就直接过去了对吧
所以而且他很多的tap可以直接跳掉
所以在最新一代里面的话呢
它其实是用tiled base的这种方法
对materia进行了极大的简化
这个具体的算法的话
大家去研究一下就可以搞得清楚
非常简单
但是呢这也反映了
就是说我们用现在的computer shader
实际上我们可以把一个复杂的full screen运算
把它切成tell分而制止
其实在我们的很多渲染里面
为什么tao base是有道理的
就是有个原因
就是比如说你这里面讲的是材质多样性
对不对
假设我场景里有上百个光源对吧
你也可以用类似的思想
就是说我每我虽然在整个屏幕上
我能看到100光源
但是的话呢在每个套里面
我可能只能看到两三光源
所以每个套里面的
我的这个光的处理数量也就两三个
那你整体上的数量就会降下来
其实跟这个是一个道理
所以这个的话呢很显然能够极大地降低
就是在材质比较复杂的情况下
它的绘制的复杂度
ok但其实这里面我再多讲一句
就是其实啊如果他的所有的texture和材质
采取的用的是virtual texture
这个思路
就是说我整个材质全拍到一个
verttt里面的话
诶
我的材质的数量
是不是也可以进一步的下降对吧
其实这也是作者在他future讲的一点
就是我未来能不能给virtual texture结合在一起
我个人觉得这个东西是verse consider
就是说很值得去思考一下好
那所以这就是它的这个材质的绘制方法
这个方法其实非常的重要
因为如果这个东西不解决的话
那你虽然做出了那么漂亮的几何啊
但是呢它和一个就是真正的
我们叫做商业级的引擎
所达到的画面还是有比较大的区别的
因为我们一个商业级引擎所达到画面的话
它的材质是要非常非常丰富的对吧
artist是绝对不允许你说你限制
我只是用一种材质的
那artist绝对要给你拼命的
那接下来这一part讲完之后呢
基本上就到后面了
后面的话呢我觉得这也是今天nut
我认为最后一个相对比较硬核的东西
就怎么做shadow
大家想象一下这么复杂的几何
你做shuttle的话是不是非常的挑战
比如说对于gi就globa nation
对低频的间接光照来讲
反正你是低频嘛
所以呢我也无所谓对吧
所以大家可以发现
就是
为什么none night可以跟lumen在一起做朋友
是因为lumen还是算了低频的间接光照
所以呢他也不一定要把几何做到这么细
这里面这是他们的内部的黑暗料理
我们就不展开
但是对于高频的就是a光的直接的shadow的话
那你对于nana来讲的话
这就很痛苦了
因为那么高密度几何我怎么去渲染他的
达到我的要要的精度对吧
所以呢其实当我们要做shadow的时候
shadow在很多时候他是个高频信号
所以呢他做shadow casting的几何的精度
要和渲染的精度是一致的
否则的话它就会出现我们不想要的
各种各样的很脏的artifacts
那这个问题怎么解决呢对吧
那你用retracing好不好
但是的话呢就是说其实not net
它的这个几何的表达是非常定制化的
也就是对现代的retracing的硬件来讲的话
他没有办法在他的那个bvh的架构里面
去表达我们nana的集合诶
这个地方的话
其实也是这一代显卡在打架的地方
就是比如说像nv的最新一个显卡
它很强调的就是
你用我自己的micro mesh的这个结构对吧
你加很多细节没关系
我给你构建
我给你构建了他的b
然后呢你对于这种机器的集合
你也能做出trc对吧
但奈的说啊
你就是做不了
我的几何是很很special的
大家如果仔细观察一下
哪来的几何的表达的话
确实是非常非常复杂
所以至少目前为止
我不知道怎么用real time
retracing的这个技术
去把这个几何在这个显卡你表达出来
所以你既然不能去把这个几何在这个显卡
你这个表达出来
让他做retracing的话
我基本上是没有办法用retracing去算他的shadow
那接下来怎么办呢
那我们先看这个最经典的shadow算法
哎我们这一趴讲的跟那个原作不太一样
就是说其实我认为他很多思想啊
实际上是源自于一些古典的图形学算法
就是其实shadow最大的问题是个采样问题
就是说随着我的相机的远近近处
我希望这个信号采样的密度要高一点对吧
因为你可能光那边的一个一个
一个小小的一个
就是一个就是shmap里面的一个txt
其实对于我屏幕上的一个pixel来讲的话
可能就是几乎是一对一的关系
但是远处的话
比如说我屏幕上的一个pixel
其实对相对外部来讲的话
可能是很大的一片区域
对不对
那这个时候呢
其实我可以用更低精度的东西
生成它的shmap
所以呢我们会有一个
就是用多层次的l o d
根据你的view dependent
我生成这样的一个shut up的精度
那这个方法就是著名的什么
其实casket shadow
就像我们前面在课程中给大家讲的
这几乎是现代游戏一个最经典的一个
shadow的这个方法
这个方法它的数学本质是什么呢
叫new dependent sembling
就是基于你的相机的位置
采取不同的这个采样精度
去深圳shadow好
那你用这个方法之后呢
哎我们假设能不能做得更精致一点呢
比如说有个方法叫sample discp的map对吧
他意识到一件事情
就是说你在在传统的这个coser shadow时候
是围绕着我的相机无脑的
一层层的变得越来越大
但是你其实真正眼睛看见的区域呢
就那么一点点对吧
所以你其实shua map
你cask shadow生成了很多的区域
其实是无效的
大家如果真的实现过一次
这个casket shmap的话
你就会发现你的
比如说最后方圆2km的那个shadow map里面
你真正用到的区域
真的就是那个一条的refresh
那个地方其实很多的选择tion
你全部是浪费掉的
所以有人就提出来说
我能不能根据your fan
真的在shut map空间里面的那条切线
我有效的生成它的shmap对吧
这样的话也能够有效的去利用它的东西
其实当我们去这样去想这个问题的时候
就让我们意识到shadomp本质
shut mc本质是什么呢
是根据我的相机的视空间的这个精度
去采样光空间诶
这个听上去非常的抽象啊
就是但是这其实是沙特曼不算法的一个
本质问题
就是说叫做为什么沙特曼有利
是因为相机空间对几何的采样和
这个几何在光空间对光的可见性
采样是两个采样的频率是不一样的
所以会产生了像我们各种各样的artifact
我一直在讲说为什么我们要加个boss呢对吧
就是因为这个产业很不准确
所以我们要加上一点容错对吧
大家还提出一种叫perspective shadow map
试图
在这两个这个这个这个这个这个两个角度
之间找到一个平衡
但这个这个算法8000年已经没有用了
是很古老的一个算法
大家不用管它好
但这个时候呢
我觉得这里面就龙这个就是说
其实这个方法的话呢
它的分布就很明显会比硬性的casket
shut up会稍微的这个更合理一点
它会把更多的精度
放在我相机相对近的地方
而在远处的话没有必要浪费那么多的精度
对吧好
这个方法是非常好的
那我们再接着讲
其实这里面的话我们必须要讲的就是
在在area 5里面
这个virtual map是这个方法
再往前一个很大的进步
我不得不承认
就是说这个方法其实非常的了不起
就是说它是对于这个采样问题的一个
本质解决
就是说那如果我把我相机看到的这个世界
根据我的resolution对吧
我近处我的采样密度要高一点
远处采样密度低一点
这是什么
这是个cp map
对不对
好
每个climap的这个区域
他在这个light space里面
我给他分一小块的这个shut map
一小块shut map
但是呢这个时map的金部
不是以我的这个世界空间的大小来定的
而是以什么呢
你在我的视空间里面的大小来定的
这样的话远处一大片区域
它在那个沙滩漫步里
只需要一小片的这个几何去表达啊
一小片的那个那个那个他要去表达
金属的话呢
哎他这个tell就很小的一块区域
在里面都有一个表达
那这样的话是不是我们完成了对shadow map
这个空间的采样的最大化的利用
对不对
而且这个东西呢
还有一个更大的好处是什么呢
就是假设我对这个空间的clip map生成啊
大家还记得我们在前面讲lumen的时候
一直在讲一件事情
就是说诶我们的value magic quemap对吧
它并不是连续生成的
它是一格一格生成的
这样的话呢我对空间的这个划分的话呢
它是在worth space为角度进行划分
那这样的好处是什么呢
当光不动的时候
我相机不动
那这个沙雕map是不是不用更新
全部在这对吧
当我在往前动的时候呢
哎我只有部分的东西需要更新
而很多东西其实我不用更新的
你想这个这个方法是不是特别的漂亮
所以virtual map它的最核心的思想就是说
我啊充分的把shadow map切成一小块一样
确保每一小块
它的这个采样率
是和我的视空间是高度对应的
那么而且呢当你的光不动的时候呢
它其实是可以储存下来的
cash下来的这一点的话其实非常重要
大家想象一下
我们在游戏的世界里面
很多时候主光源是基本不动的对吧
太阳就是那个角度
所以的话哎
我这个地方的数据的成功率就非常的高
那么实际上的话呢nat它这里面的shadow
因为它的几何密度实在太高了对吧
那他怎么办
他其实也用的是这个virtual shadow map方法
它就是对于每一个光源对吧
我就给死了一个16k升
16k的一个大的这个沙袋buff buff
那么这样的话呢
就是说我就会去算
我的每一个在试空间里面
你看到这里面不同的颜色
就表示你相机看过去
这里面对应的是那个不是版本的一个top
所需要的集合
那么这个时候呢
我就可以使我算这个
这个这个这个每一小块的这个shadow的时候
我就在那个不是沙滩外面找到那个tell
去判断它的光源的可见性
但这里面有个有意思的这个细节
就是说如果你不小心你放了一个点光源
我们的rs特别喜欢在里面放点光源
放一盏灯对吧
顶高原呢它对世界的投影是六个q
反正我们看了一下那个arl的源代码
就是你放了一个点光源
它会生成六个16k乘16k的
不是ture的mp
我个人一想
我说哇我的天呐
这个实在太废了
但没关系吧
反正就是说他确实是能够解决这个问题
那么其实你对不同的light light type的话
你会发现他对这个时空间的几何
这个这个这个tell的划分
它是不一样的对吧
如果你是这个spotlight
你是这个就是这个点光源
你是方向光
它的划分就是不一样啊
你可以发现就是比如最它的左上的那个啊
就右上那个点的话
就是一个方向光源形成的这样一个跑分
那么这个方法呢看上去是非常的复杂
但实际上这些配置啊
他的allocation每一次只要分配部分的东西
如果你的相机和光源都不变的时候
它不用重新allocation对吧
当你的相机动的时候呢
它实际上只需要更新这里面部分的tad的
上来map就可以了
就相当于我们以前做cascade的话
我们要画一个很大的一个一大片集合
但今天的话我只画一小片那个几何
我跟光相关的那个
它其实那个锥很小很小
所以大量的物体都会被cut掉
所以它的更新效率是非常高的
那么这个shadow map的配置
这个在washutmvm里面的话
它invalidation的case其实是非常简单的
第一个你相机移动对吧
但是呢你相机移动如果是smooth的话
它实际上只有部分的配置需要更新
当你的光一旦动了之后
那没办法
所有的沙雕map都要变
所以说当你用vtusha map的时候呢
那尽量选择这个主光是不动的场景
所以大家去看那个u v5 的那个demo的时候
很多时候那个光都是固定在那儿对吧
那个那个最酷的那个山谷的那种
那个光就直直的就射下来了
那么还有就是说这个节目水本身动的时候
这个筛掉也会变
但是呢你也可以把这个变化更local一点
那么还有很多一些一些一些一些原理
就会产生变化了
那么我们这里面自己是我们课程组
自己做了一个实验
就是说我们搭了一个场景
然后呢
当我们的光就是当我们去推进相机的时候
主观不变的
你会发现那个那些绿色的那些切片
那些那些山
我去山版的那个套
它基本上是不用更新的
只有少量的那个红色的那些套
需要更新一下
大家发现没有
他其实需要更新的地方是非常的少
这也是这个方法的巧妙之处
但是呢它这个方法有一个很大的好处
是什么呢
它所生成的shadow的质量是非常非常高的
这比传统的cascade的shadow质量要高
而且呢以前casket shadow map有个问题
就是说当我相机移动的时候
因为我不同的层级之间的shadow
它是有个transition的嘛
你可以很明显的感受到
那个shadow是有一个popping的
就是说诶我从l d0 的shadow map到d一的时候
到l d2 的时候
你可以看到邦德瑞那个几何是一个popping的
那个那个shadow是个popping的
但是用vr sem的时候
你可以发现它的shadow基本是很稳定
而且这套pipeline的话也可以非常柔和的
非常naturally的跟那个nt结合在一起
所以呢这个我也是认为
就是说这是由于我非常了不起的一个发明
我个人认为是啊
有可能应该是大概率可能会取代掉casket
sha map的下一代的shadow的技术
因为从他的数学原理上来讲的话
我觉得还是用那个词叫做非常的elegant
非常的优美
非常优雅对
所以说呢其实就是说这个virtual smap的话呢
也是一个大家如果想去理解nas
整个的rendering pipeline的话
一定要去理解的一个基础算法
ok好
那最后呢其实是作者讲了很多了
就是说啊我们这个nana的技术对吧
当我们去处理这样的开放世界的时候
我们就可以进行streaming了
多么的了不起啊
但其实我个人觉得这里面的
有些很大部分的实现的话
还是比较自然而然的
因为你既然已经构建了这样的一个b vh
啊
这样的一个tree的结ree的结构的话
你可以很自然地根据you dependent对吧
我可以只露的一些hello
我的降水
然后呢我再去下面构建它的这个lol的降水
他会把这个降水的话呢
构建成一个一个的page对吧
这样的话一块一块的往里面加载
这个其实在我们的很多的系统里面
是一个很常用的一个技术对吧
那么另外一个当然了
这个技术对他来讲的话
就是说诶我终于把几何像virtual text一样
可以叫用到即下载
不用急不下载
这个如果我想做一个基于这么nt的技术
这可能是我有必须要用的一个技术
这个我认为还是有道理的
那么另外一个的话呢就是拿他的一个痛点
就是说哎呀
我的这个数据量实在太大了对吧
那他就要对数据进行压缩
其实它的压缩呢我个人看了一下嗯
还是比较好理解的
就是说对于内存中的数据呢
它一般用的是quanzation
什么叫quanzation的话
我记得我在之前讲到那个
好多地方都讲到这个概念对吧
表现动画就是说原来你是浮点型的
我把你把把你变成定点型
比如说你的vertex的位置对吧
我如果知道一个cluster的这个
这个这个bbox的话
实际上我这里面的这个很多的位置
我实际上是可以把它
就是这个那个把它给定点化了
比如说像罗al对吧
我不需要精度那么高
我也可以定点化uv
也可以定电话对吧
这样的话我可以节约出来我的存储空间
那么这个的话好处就是说你访问他
对它进行反向的低矿的效率都非常的高
那么对于这个存储在磁盘上的东西的话呢
他就用了hardware lz decompression对吧
lz compression这件事情本身啊
应该说是最效率最高的
而且很多硬件可以支持的一个压缩和解
压缩算法
应该是microsoft的和啊
md还nvidia的dk里面有一个叫做direct storage
就是说你从磁盘中读一个数据
不用过cpu
不用过主内存
直接可以读到
那个就是我的显存中间去读的数据过程中
我还可以自动地对数据进行解压缩
这个解压缩算法如果没记错的话
就是la的算法
这样的话实际上我就可以实现
就是比如说像在我记得如果没记错
在cs上就有这个东西
那我就可以实现那个哎非常多的数据
在磁盘中
快速的
这个磁盘
本身
也是那个就是那个那个那个
就是那个这个那个叫什么h d d对吧
不是hdd
说错了
是那个就是s s d
是我的那个就是固态硬盘
我的数据可以直接到显存里面去
而且到显存的过程中
它自动就被解压缩了
那这样的话呢就可以被解压缩
所以我觉得他提到的这个数据的streaming啊
无限可以扩展的世界的话
这也是一个大家很自然的一个想法
当然了其实也讲到了很多的时间细节
比如说为了提高lz压缩的这个效率
他就想到了说诶
我要在里面加一些padding的data对吧
然后让他那个lz的字典的命中率更高
这样获得一个更高的这样压缩效率
其实原作者其实还是分享了很多小的
trick的
也就是说整个nana在我的看法来讲的话呢
就是说
首先是个非常了不起的一个工程思想
那么另外一点的话
就是说
作者确实他们这个整个团队在工程上
把这一代硬件的性能基本是压榨到极致了
所以这里面大家如果想学这个
就是一些高性能的编程啊
这在他的实践中可以学到很多
有意思的东西好
那么其实的话拿来的话呢
它本身它的主要算法就是这些东西对吧
这个很巨大的数据量
我在这边整个跑通了对吧
那今天这节课基本上全部讲完了
我今天还是老问题
就是当我把所有的ppt写完之后
我发现我的时间已经out了
我其实很想写几句很感性的话
就是说哎呀这个这么复杂的技术
到底在讲什么东西
但是呢我后来觉得用这句话
可能能代表我对这个这个未来的理解
就是说其实下一代的游戏
那你必须要有一套全新的几何管线
能够处理
能够憨豆这些复杂的事件
那这里面的话呢
我们也给大家分享一个
我们课程组制作的一个小视频
这个视频是什么呢
就是这是nas demo里面
当我们用相机钻下去看你看到的那个山谷
它下面有多少层的这个几何的细节
层叠而成
所以大家可以想象
就是现代的计算机的这个处理能力之强
就是这么多层
就是达到像素级精度的三角形
一层一层一层叠在一起
形成了我们所看到的这个
丰富的几何的世界
所以的话呢
这也是我觉得我们的这个就是未来
顶级游戏作品的一个未来吧
就是我们必须在一步步的逼近
这个电影级的影视级的画面
这也是我们一代代游戏人
游戏引擎人的一个梦想
好
这也是作为我这个104课程
最后一趴的这个感想
好的谢谢大家
那接下来呢我们就是q n a的环节
q n环节之后
大家不要跑
我们会有我们课程的花旦好不好
ok那最后呢就是给大家分享一下
我们这边课程的reference
这边看的reference reference不多
因为他的资料并不多
其实我们大部分的东西都是肯代码
啃出来的
ok好那就是也感谢我们的团队
就是真的非常的辛苦大家
这个在这个过去的一个月里面
真的花了很多的精力把这个东西给啃透
那好的
同学们有没有什么问题
第一个问题
同学问我说nana的这种无限精度的几何
可以无无极渐变的这种几何表达方式
会不会成为未来几何表达的主流方式啊
就是说我觉得确实非常的promising
就是真的很有可能
但是呢其实这里面的话
有几种不同流派的方法
大家也在compete
比如说null本身是做了大量的工程妥协嘛
而且他这个算法本身非常复杂
它本身对于比如说啊skinny geometry
就是带有比如说我们大量用的角色
他没有办法表达对吧
对一些动态的集合它也比较难以表达
那么但是的话呢
就是说确实它让我们第一次在游戏里看到
这种实时的cinematic级别的
这样的几何细节
所以其实所以呢我我们在猜测就是在未来
随着硬件的发展
可能有一些更简洁
更elegant的方法会成为主流
因为其实我们观察整个就是引擎行业
过去几十年的发展
就是一个新的思想出来之后
都要经过好几代的
不同的就是开发者共同去迭代
形成一个共识
形成我们一代的papi
就像我们讲的deer shading对吧
也是经过了很多代的迭代
才能形成我们现在这样一个成熟度
那么反过来讲
厂商也在疯狂的努力想去解决这个问题
所以的话呢我觉得这两条路
两条腿到底谁能够跑得更快一点
我觉得在未来几年的话
大家会看到非常精彩的一个
你追我赶的过程
所以现在的话呢说这件事情大局已定的话
还为时尚早了一点啊
第二个问题是大家问我说
not let的应用空间是不是不止游戏领域
这个答案是一定是yes
因为其实现在可以发现
就是很多我们用游戏引擎做的这个渲染
已经可以逼近于影视级的需要了
我们已经看到很多的
比如说虚拟拍摄
他就用这样的一个nasa的技术
就做一个巨大的led的屏对吧
上面有上亿个像素在里面
绘制的山和水非常的真实
然后演员在那个l e d屏前面
就直接进行表演
然后一起拍摄下来
那个感觉就像你真的在实景中
其实在影视啊
在游戏之外的各个领域里面
比如说在这种病对吧
比如说像智慧城市这样
或者建筑的这种光照仿真里面的话啊
建筑可能不需要
就是我们自然场景的表达吧
所以很多时候都需要拿来的这样的一个技
术好的
那我们今天的问题就到这吧
我们的games 104课程
到这一趴就完美的杀青了
也不见不能叫完美吧
说实话还是蛮感动的
因为这200多天吧
就是从一开始决定开始做这个课的时候
只是一个冲动
但是没有想到冲动的代价是这么的惨烈
然后就是确实大家坐进去之后
觉得这是一个一种本能
或者说我们觉得是一份责任
其实这个课程实际上准备过程中
我觉得我们有蛮多的遗憾
就是很多东西没有做到
我们想要的这个结果
我们很希望说能给我们再来一次的机会
把很多课程讲得更好
但是呢我们确实尽了我们的权力
那我觉得其实为什么要做这门课的话
我觉得用一句话形容
就是每一个想做引擎的同学
他的心里都是有光的
所以我们想把这种光传递给越来越多的人
让大家真的敢于去构建自己的世界
真的去探索这个技术的最前沿的东西
其实我们自己也在这个道路上
其实很多的挑战很艰难
但是的话我觉得把这份光
这份热爱分享给所有不肯放弃的人
我们在一起
然后我们争取以后再见
我们后面跟大家一直在一起
好谢谢大家games 104
先我们说个拜拜
我们争取明年再见哦